regi Aloysius Miller Hall of Famer he
called Kansas Oregon Elite Eight game on
Saturday night before I talked to a
March Madness reg first of all good
morning good morning Devin Booker scores
70 in a game what do you make of that
game and the celebration after loss when
you score 70 highly impressed by the 70
points I think if anytime at any level
you for 70 points is a heck of an
accomplishment not a fan of a
celebration it's because we're almost
celebrating losing and is that what the
game has come to I understand the seat
but you posed in the locker room
afterwards with him holding the 70 sign
like will I'm not a big fan of that and
I'm not a big fan of how they went about
getting him that 70 you know fouling
down the stretch give him you know extra
opportunities and possessions to shoot
the basketball I've always been a big
proponent of you never want to mess with
the basketball God and I believe the the
sons kind of mess with the basketball
gods to me it wasn't as organic as like
you know when Michael Jordan had 69
versus the Celtics during a playoff game
both things came within the flow of the
offense and it was a close game if you
go back and look at that game the Suns
were down by 20 plus minutes most of the
game and then they started following to
get him extra possession so look 70 I
don't want to be that guy you know that
old guy oh my god hating on the younger
generation because 70 points to 70
points don't get me wrong he's 20 years
of age 20 years of age and getting 70
and I look and for the subject to be
hating on them I will be embarrassed to
for 20 year-old gave me 70 I get that
but the way they would about it and the
fouling and the celebrating after a loss
when you were down by 20 plus points the
whole game it wasn't like they were down
you know they pulled away late
they were down 20 plus points most of
game one other thing I wanted to ask you
in relating to the NBA is these college
kids in March Madness can you is there
any extra value to what you think of
their draft status of how they play in
March Madness or would you just look at
the regular season to assess how good
somebody is because thorn wells gonna
raise his draft status with his
performance but sometimes we have it
gets tricky where we raise somebody's
status because they continue to play
through March Madness and then we see
them more and more and then it feels
like people fall in love with them well
certainly you get extra eyes on certain
players as they continue to advance
during the tournament and if you're a
scout is just another tool for you to
kind of gauge you know what type of
player and you know are these young men
you know pressure players you know and
obviously when you're in a one-and-done
situation and a winner-take-all
situation like the NCAA tournament is I
guess it's a good little gauge for
scouts to look at certain players to see
you know how do they perform under
pressure can they make the same shots do
they make their teammates and the
players around them better so I you know
if you're a scout is just another way to
gauge you know if these guys are you
know primetime players and can play at
the next level but would it hurt
somebody's draft stock by how they
played in March Madness in these big
certainly if it's gonna help you it
certainly can hurt you as well
especially if you don't perform well
yeah I think the knife cuts both ways
we had Patrick Ewing on last week and he
told us that it came down to Georgetown
and UCLA so he would have been I think
you kidding me did you know that know
who dropped the ball he said they'd let
me get on the plane to go back that
never should have happened you would
have been a sophomore I think when he
was a senior oh my god are you are you
telling me that Patrick Ewing could have
been in blue and gold yes that was his
second civilian yes that never should've
happened
he said they had too many guys you like
to shoot on that team that's why he
couldn't go there oh wow are you kidding
me I mean I can't fault him playing for
John Thompson and you know going to
Georgetown but it really came down to
the yes yeah I was submitted yeah I
didn't know that it came down to UCLA in
Georgetown I'm surprised well that hurts
because right now he probably would have
been the third best center now maybe he
would have been the second best dinner I
think he would have jumped big bill no
even though you know big bill during
college he would've been the third guy
yeah yeah he wouldn't a surpassed him in
the pros he would he went up half the
big we're talking about Reggie Miller
has no NBA or NC double-a duties this
week but there's there's something on
CBS on Saturday called the shooter
what's your involvement in that yeah
it's called the shooter I did a feature
and it gets to be a chance I go back to
the dental offices I've actually been on
the court and actually worked out in you
know in full lather I go back in all the
iconic NC a moment shots that happen
Michael Jordan for Georgetown Mario
Chalmers if you remember that shot
versus Memphis Scotty Thurman we
recreate all these shots the Christian
Laettner play Steph Curry that shot in
and Davidson smart the big shot to die
you versus Syracuse I believe yeah and
then we all end with the you know what
we kind of ranked them but not really
we're gonna give a chance to fans the
kind of way in which shot did you think
was the greatest and then we end with
obviously Christian can shot last year
with Villanova so I'm on the floor and
we recreate all these shots and what's
the mentality of a shooter you know this
is a moment for these young men what is
it like what are they thinking what was
Michael Jordan thinking as a freshman
when really it was Sam Perkins and James
were these team the ball is coming to
him in the year so I kind of take the
fans
through what maybe these guys were
thinking so it's called the shooter it
airs on CBS this Saturday so hopefully
you'll like it we get to recreate some
of the most iconic shots from the NCAA
tournament what was the toughest one to
recreate I would probably say the
Laettner one just for the simple fact I
didn't know that he had dribbled once
and because we had to like I had to go
over it three or four times he
pump-faked to his right and then shot
over his left shoulder and to its
recreating the celebration - I was you
know I tried to get into the Grant Hill
and the Thomas Hill poles when he was
crying on the sideline so it's the
celebration to that you got to recreate
so probably the later one was the
toughest Jordan was you know Jordan was
a pretty simple shot yeah that was
pretty easy
Chalmers I thought was pretty tough
because it was one dribble and the point
guard was falling down as he kind of
flipped flipped it to him so it was fun
to do
speaking of of crying last time you
cried at a sporting event watching a
sporting event we had Darius Rucker on
last hour and Darius was full tears
after South Carolina one yesterday
sporting event would probably be 1994
Game seven in the Madison Square Garden
locker room that run that we had
wouldn't you know no one expected us to
get all the way to the Conference Finals
versus the Knicks and they burst our
bubble we should have wanted in Game six
in Market Square Arena they tied it up
we went back to the garden and I had a
shot that went a little bit left and in
the locker room the emotions came out
that was probably the last time and I
told myself the only other time I'll
ever cry again is if I win a
championship so again I have not cried
obviously do the missus stay with you
longer than the makes yep yep people
always say oh my god you're eight point
- nine seconds or the 25 point quarter
or the shot versus Jordan - push I'll
come those are so great dope all the
misses I relive all the tough moments as
a toast to all the great ones it's
that's just who I am I don't I can't say
that's the same for everyone but it's
those tough games that I remember the
most as opposed to the big moments
Charles Barkley was in last week and I
asked him a variety of questions I also
I asked him this and he he said it was a
no-brainer I said would you rather have
christian Laettner 'he's career or manu
ginóbili 'he's career no I'm
incorporating everything so
international play college and pros who
I will go with oh that's a good one I'll
go with Manu Ginobili okay so did
Charles yeah because he's an
international superstar because he had a
great career for the Argentine national
team so they won a gold medal there then
to win three with the Spurs I'll go with
Manu
what about Laettner or Robert Horry Oreo
oh come on no question big shot big shot
hat big shot has some another iconic
moment at the pro level definitely big
shot Bob really yeah but let me say this
Christian Laettner collegiate career you
could make a case that he is arguably
the greatest college player ever and I
know that's up again will our excuse me
that's up against Kareem that's up
against Bill Russell that's up against
Bill Walton you can make a case he had
the greatest four-year run ever
he's got College immortality I'm not
saying he is I'm saying you could make a
case well he's certainly top seven or
lower all-time as far as high five I
guess what the biggie Elvin Hayes would
you put in there no he didn't win the
title
okay well Kareem and Bill cream cream to
me is the greatest college basketball
player bill the
bill yeah he won two titles deal would
be top five yeah I would think we're
just talking about college our ears yes
I don't know if you could put Jordan in
there but he stayed three years right
yeah he won one title he wanted one
title and and he had one of those iconic
moment now you know I would put Patrick
Ewing above Jordan you could put yes
certainly
yeah he has a title with g-town and what
he went to two finals to lost one in one
one right yeah yeah and I might put him
above Jordan err yes a Christian I had a
Laettner I he was a better player but
Laettner has a better resume
Laettner Laettner hit every big shot man
every every you know there's another
Danny Manning Danny Manning could be in
there too
with what he did that one year was it's
incredible with Kansas uh it's very in
there too
no they didn't they didn't win a title I
don't think they lost a Louisville I
know but I don't remember him winning a
title would you put man he wouldn't put
Manning ahead of Laettner no what about
Pete Maravich did they ever win no okay
that goes through the biggie right heck
of scores right both of them were
unbelievable with the ball and scoring
yes didn't win yeah alright so the
shooter is on Saturday Saturday night
Saturday pregame on CBS okay ground a
chance to relive some of the most iconic
shots I take you into what those guys
were thinking as the ball was coming to
them and the clock is ticking down low
it was fun yeah and I didn't mention you
know who this time around thank God I'm
just saying I get it but enough is
enough already okay we're not even gonna
have no problems I have no problem with
Lavar ball
I don't it's just some of the things
that he's saying I I don't think it's
fair to the kids but if they don't care
about it why should I care about it he's
Reggie Aloysius Miller off tournament
duty and you can see the shooter on
Saturday pregame reg great job in the
tournament we enjoyed it have fun on
your week off there but I appreciate it
thank you so much and before I go out of
the final four who do you have
I have Carolina yeah I see redemption
enter you know what this reminds me of
it reminds me of San Antonio Spurs
remember when Ray Allen hit the shot to
tie it in get him six and then they went
on to win ever remember the people were
roping this they were roping the corn
off already thinking that San Antonio
was gonna win all they needed was one
possession and then Ray Allen became
Superman and in the next year they came
back got into the finals and wanted it
kind of reminds me a little bit North
Carolina like that like last year Marcus
Paige double clutch they should have won
but Chris Jenkins shot and now they're
back in the same situation I'm going to
roll with you on that
you're a Larson tour yeah I read em
thank you buddy thank god that's Reggie
Aloysius Miller the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience